it's been a good few days for Donald
Trump on the Republicans all-powerful
Rules Committee an attempt to stoke
rebellion against him ended in failure
and he picked a new partner for the
campaign trail his running mate Mike
Pence a steady conservative to reassure
the party faithful I'm a Christian a
conservative and a Republican in that
order but not everything is rosy
Cleveland is on edge amid fears of
violent protests against the man who
would be president the center of the
city is in a virtual lockdown with
police and federal agents everywhere to
be seen and within the Republican Party
Trump has still failed to unite powerful
figures behind him in fact the last two
Republican presidents are boycotting the
convention both george w bush and his
father george bush senior are staying
away and the same goes for Mitt Romney
and John McCain the party's last two
candidates for the White House but Trump
shows no signs of caring and on Thursday
night he'll deliver his big speech
doubtless with some themes that got him
so far we're gonna build a huge
beautiful extravagant wall and not only
is Mexico gonna build the wall they're
gonna pay for it - then comes Trump's
next big battle against Hillary Clinton
a battle of personalities and what kind
of country America wants to be